foreign
my name is Joe Sanford I am a professor
at UW Platteville in the school of AG
I'm also associated with the Wisconsin
Dairy Innovation Hub
um and so today I'm going to talk a
little bit about some of the ongoing
research we have going into adding
biochar into manure management
and so before we start getting into it
too much
um
what is biochar for those who may not be
as familiar with it biochar is a product
of a process called pyrolysis where
essentially we're just taking a biomass
that can really be any organic biomass
wood chips corn Stover straw manure
putting it into a reactor with low
oxygen content at very high temperatures
we're talking 600 and 900 degrees
Fahrenheit or higher and out of this
process what we end up with is a syngas
and a bio oil both of these products can
be used for energy production or Heating
and then we end up with a biochar as
well which is this charcoal looking
material down here
here's some material that's been made in
our lab from a lot of different things
and so biochar has a lot of interesting
characteristics very similar to
activated carbon not the same thing but
does have some similar characteristics
it has a very high carbon content it has
a high surface area alkaline pH and
generally has a fairly good exchange
capacity with nutrients and other
elements
and so biochar has been around for quite
a while
um and it's been primarily used as a
soil amendment
um and so biochar has been applied to a
lot of different types of soils a lot of
different production systems
um and you know the kind of conclusions
from a lot of the research you can find
out there is that it's been shown to
help improve nutrient retention this is
a study that was done by a graduate
student in my old Lab at UW-Madison with
Becky Larson that found that soils
amended with biochar that receive manure
application if we amended it with
biochar we could see significant
reductions in total nitrogen leaching
significant reductions in in nitrate
leaching as well it's also been found to
increase water use efficiency and
sandier soils increase aeration
and porosity and more clay soils some
Studies have found it to reduce soil
emissions I put a little asterisk there
because the research isn't really
conclusive yeah there's a lot of
different opinions on this right now
um but a big one that's receiving a lot
of tension right now is biochar's
potential to sequester carbon and so
um if you're in in ag I'm sure you've
heard about all the carbon credits going
around anaerobic digestion things like
that carbon sequestration is a is
becoming a Hot Topic and
um agriculture is kind of seen as as the
place for biochar and this quest to
sequester carbon is kind of the place
for that biochar to go and so one thing
my research group has been looking at is
yes it'd be nice to apply biochar to
sequester carbon improve nutrient
intention things like that but how else
might we be able to use biochar in a
manure management system to
get more benefits out of the product
and so what my research group at
Platteville has been doing has been
looking at different areas that we can
add biochar into the manure management
system one of these areas is compost
this is probably one of the most studied
areas when it comes to waste management
and biochar is composting biochar has
been found to have some benefits in
composting particularly around nitrogen
retention in the form of nitrogen in the
compost
we've also seen out of Europe quite a
bit of research into actually
incorporating biochar into animal feed
as well right now I'm not actively
looking into those there's some
literature out there I'd be happy to
share with anyone that's interested but
my research group right now has been
looking at
actually using that manure from manure
solid so if we have solid liquid
separator we're separating out those
solids taking those solids drying them
down and converting them into biochar as
a another potential export from the farm
we've also been looking at using it as a
cover on the top of manure storages and
also incorporating it into anaerobic
digestion systems and so for the rest of
my my time I'm going to talk a little
bit about these these different studies
that we have ongoing and some of the
preliminary results we've been seeing
so making biochar out of manure
um this was a project that I started on
uh back at you uh in UW at UW-Madison
with Becky Larson
um looking at phosphorus Management in
Wisconsin and biochar and um for those
of you who may not are
in Most states where we have a lot of
livestock production a lot of kfos we
have an issue where you know we have a
concentration of animals we have a
concentration of manure and generally
Around The Farmstead that manure is
being applied and in particular in
Wisconsin we have a lot of issues with
the buildup of phosphorus in that soil
leading to some Legacy phosphorus issues
and so a lot of research has gone into
how can we better manage our manure
phosphorus particularly in areas where
we have high concentrations of animals
quite a few Studies have come out of the
ew Madison groups kind of looking at
different areas of concern and different
methods and the conclusion for it is is
that really we need to find a way to
help densify the phosphorus in manure
and try to export it from some
watersheds where we have a particularly
high amount of livestock production
um and so solid liquid separation is one
way to get a little bit of phosphorus
out a lot of Studies have found that
it's still a little too wet for
economically transport reporting fairly
significant distances and so what we've
been looking at is taking that manure
solid densifying it through the biocharb
or the pyrolysis process and then
shipping that out potentially as a as an
agronomic fertilizer
and so here's some results that we
published a couple years ago on this
topic here so the figure up here
um in my lab I have this little tiny
biochar unit this was the material that
went into the biochar the same mass and
this is what came out and so you can see
here there's a really large reduction in
the volume of that material it's a large
reduction in the mass of that material
well it makes it a little bit more
feasible than to potentially transport
further distances and so what we wanted
to look at in the first part of this
study was what happens to the nutrients
in the material
and so the figure on the left here this
is the phosphorus concentration this is
kind of what we're targeting here to see
how we could densify the phosphorus
taking the manure drying it and then
going to biochar at two different
temperatures what we found was that we
could really increase or densify that
phosphorus into this biochar product
when we did a mass balance through the
system
um we essentially lost no phosphorus so
we retained about 100 of the phosphorus
there's a little bit of losses probably
from user error
um but we retained all that phosphorus
and so we were able to densify that
phosphorus from the manure solids into a
very lightweight product that could
potentially then be shipped out on the
nitrogen side of things we did also see
a densification in terms of nitrogen in
the product so in terms of pounds of
nitrogen per ton
of wet weight we did see more nitrogen
in that material however if you did a
mass balance here what we found is we
lost about 40 to 60 percent of the
nitrogen when it went through pyrolysis
and this is primarily due to
volatilization of of nitrogen off of
that process
and so right now we're kind of looking
at
um you know yeah we can densify the
phosphorus what does that mean though if
we use it then as a fertilizer somewhere
else so we did a small incubation study
this is some results from that looking
at phosphorus available phosphorus and
some soil incubation studies over time
what we found was that compared to the
regular manure saws there's a little bit
of a lag in the biochar in terms of
available phosphorus first but over time
it was statistically the same all right
over the growing season so right now
what we're doing is we're transitioning
some larger field studies to keep
exploring this is an option and get some
more data and seeing how we can
incorporate into some of our production
systems in Wisconsin
the next area I want to talk about
adding a biochar to manure systems is uh
manure storages and so manure storages
are essential to a lot of our operations
particularly large operations
however there are some concerns
particularly around emissions so our
manure storages are going to emit quite
a bit of methane they're going to emit
some nitrous oxide and also some ammonia
or we're gonna have some nitrogen losses
from that manure storage and so changes
in the industry particularly water use
has resulted in manure storages looking
less like this and more like this not
having this natural crust and what we've
seen is that particularly ammonia
emissions have increased when we have no
crust on the surface and so what we want
to look at is can we use biochar as a
surface cover over these more liquidy
storages to help reduce particularly
ammonia emissions and maybe some
greenhouse gases as well
and so we've been working on some pilot
studies here about to transition some
larger scale studies
um and so what we've found is we had our
manure storages which were five gallon
buckets essentially we filled them with
manure we had some controls we applied
covers over the top of this so this is
some wood chips that were not processed
into biochar some wood chips that were
and we measured ammonia Emissions on a
weekly basis and also greenhouse gas
Emissions on a weekly basis to kind of
tracked what the emissions were and what
we found was pretty Stark in terms of
emissions of ammonia from that control
wood chips we also did a corn Stover
those two covers did reduce ammonia
emissions but when we added biochar into
the mix we took that material made into
biochar where wood chips we almost
eliminated ammonia emissions off that
storage and for corn Stover we had a
fairly large reduction as well and so
what was going on here uh what we kind
of found is that that cover stability is
really important so biochar is fairly
hydrophobic for the most part
um and what we saw was that the cover
staying on the surface of that bio of
that manure storage was really essential
and so this is the storages initially
this is about two or three days after we
applied the cover here we see both
covers you know on top but after about a
month that that biomass started to sink
however biochar was still pretty much
just as good as it was on day one and so
this is what we think was the primary
driver here I mean this has been a
complaint of producers that do use
permeable covers as a as a mechanism for
ammonia where they they sink and they
have they require frequent reapplication
so biochar really does seem to be a
potential method to reduce the
applications of that permeable cover and
help reduce ammonia emissions
the next topic I want to talk about
um is adding biochar to anaerobic
digestion systems this is an area that's
I've gotten a lot of questions about
recently and so for those of you in the
room I'm sure you're familiar with
anaerobic digestion of manure we're
taking the manure putting in a reactor
we're getting biogas we convert that
into energy there's a lot of benefits on
the digestate side as well however a
major problem with anaerobic digestion
and particularly Dairy manure is that we
feed a lot of sulfur to our animals and
that sulfur when it gets in this
anaerobic condition
turns into hydrogen sulfide through
sulfur reduction and so hydrogen sulfide
is a is a really costly part of the
operational budget for removing it takes
around 15 to 20 percent of your animal
operation budget is put just towards
removing hydrogen sulfide so that we can
use that biorgas for some sort of energy
purpose
and so what we've been doing this is
this is um kind of coming off of some
work that had been done by Becky Larson
at Madison
um expanding upon that but I was looking
at adding biochar to anaerobic digestion
systems quite a few people have looked
at this in terms of reducing methane but
we wanted to look at and see what its
impact was on hydrogen sulfide so in our
lab we've been looking at multiple
different types of biochars and adding
them in batch reactors and then
analyzing the hydrogen sulfide methane
and the biogas quantity off these
reactors when we add biochar into the
reactors at relatively low ratios in
terms of a mass ratio
and what we found has been pretty uh
Stark removal of of biochar of hydrogen
sulfide and so this is from a study my
undergrad finished up about two months
ago
um at uw-platteville and what we did in
this study is we had controls which were
just manure with some digestate from a
local farm and then we added biochars
produced at different temperatures
starting around the lower end of what we
consider biochar production to the
higher end and looked at hydrogen
sulfide production over the course of
the period and what we found was that by
adding biochar particularly low
temperature biochars we could
significantly reduce hydrogen sulfide
production when we did a mass balance of
hydrogen sulfur produced compared to the
biogas produced as well we found we had
around a 70 to 80 percent reduction when
we added biochar in the range of 660
degree Fahrenheit to 930. when we get to
that higher temperature we're still
trying to figure out what exactly is
going on here so I'm not going to have
answers to that questions if they're out
there but high temperature biochars are
not great at reducing hydrogen sulfide
and we've seen this with a couple other
biomasses as well so this is some Aspen
wood
um really not having much effect very
similar to control
um so we're not 100 sure what's
happening here but the results that
we've gotten so far has really shown
that low temperature biochars are very
effective at mitigating hydrogen sulfide
production during anaerobic digestion of
livestock manure
so that is what I wanted to talk about
today in terms of biochar and adding it
to manure Management Systems um just a
few take-home messages here you know
biochar has been shown to have a lot of
potential as a soil amendment and kind
of what my group has been looking at is
how can we increase the uses of it in
manure management so that there's maybe
some more adoption of it and so we're
looking at a lot of different things and
a lot of different benefits that biochar
could potentially have in these manure
Management systems and I think a key
takeaway from what I talked about today
is that not all biochar is the same the
temperature the feedstock that the
biochar is produced at is important on
your end goal and so recognizing that
when you are
thinking about adding biochar thinking
about encouraging a producer to add
biochar to their manure management
system is important
uh one thing I didn't talk about uh
which I'm sure there will be questions
on is the cost and so it's kind of the
elephant in the room biochar production
is going to be a fairly high cost
particularly if we're trying to do it on
Farm it's going to be a high capital
investment to put in a biochar
production system on Farm however I
think with the carbon credits and the in
the way we're seeing anaerobic digestion
moving right now I think in the near
future there may be some incentives to
start thinking about this biochar and
lowering the cost a little bit
and so with that just want to say thank
you here's my contact information if
you'd like to uh shoot me an email or
follow me on Twitter and the research I
presented today has been funded both by
the dairy Hub in Wisconsin and uh the
USDA nifa program
[Music]